- A video went ridiculously viral--
- I got, I got, I got
- on the internet, about
a kid trying to get
a job with us at Vayner.
♫ Internship on internship
inside my resume
- It's okay, Brett, let it play.
I love how you looked as if your alarm
is gonna stop me from doing this setup.
- [Brett] Just to remind
you to buy chocolate.
- I know, I'm buying
chocolate. (bell dings)
Listen.
This kid hacked it.
This interview, meeting, opportunity,
fairy tale ending, growth hacking strategy
is a very worthwhile video for all of you.
Please pay attention.
Do the homeworks.
Teams, let's link some of the
coverage and the reddit thread
and the other things
that came along with this
incredible interview
with this wonderful kid
who has now got something very
good coming up in the future.
♫ It's legit, never quit
♫ I'm a different applicant
- So, man, you made it.
- Yeah man.
- You figured it out.
Tell me the whole story.
- Alright, I'll start from the beginning.
I got, I got, I got,
I found out about you
through The Breakfast Club.
- I'm gonna spell it out for you.
G-O-O-G-L-E.
Go to (bleep) Google and type
in, "How do I make money?"
"How do I start a business?"
There's a lot of things you can do.
- And through the Brilliant Edits podcast.
- But are you willing to bleed
out of your fucking eyes for your dream?
The answer is, you're not,
'cause you're full of shit.
- So I'd seen you on there,
and I was digging what you were saying,
and over the past, I don't know,
seven months since I discovered you,
I feel like sometimes you're tugging at me
while I'm at work listening to you,
like, "Man, you're gonna quit your job."
(laughter)
- Just like a voice?
- Yeah, yeah, I like my
job, but I know that.
- What do you do?
- I work for a night club, Lava Nightclub.
It's under--
- I know.
- Casino, you know?
- I, pretty much, do all
the flyers and stuff.
Pretty much, I feel like I'm coming up.
- Design?
- Yeah.
I feel like I'm turning into
a one trick pony.
If I stay too long.
- I get it.
♫ In that visual communications I got BFA.
Pretty much.
- So I'm whispering in
your ear, virtually.
- Yeah, maybe about a week before
you guys put up the Are
You a Creator video.
- Calling all creators right now.
I need to create a content army.
- There was a kid that used to work here.
His name was Pomsey.
And, by chance, I just happened
to get on YouTube and I seen this video
about how he got the job at Vayner.
I just reached out to him on Instagram
and I just offered him some value.
I know video kids, they need graphics
just to save them time.
So I'm like, "Hey man, I'll do something
"like lower third graphics for
you or something, whatever."
And then, he was down with it.
It didn't end up working how we
wanted it to but we kept
in touch and everything.
From there, I was just
trying to figure out
how I could do the same thing he did
but in my own way because I know
you guys said you have 150 applicants
and 4,000 views and I'm like,
how the heck am I gonna stand out.
And I know you like rap music.
I was like man, if he could hear me spit
I think he'd be impressed.
♫ You should hire me not simply
♫ 'Cause I mailed an inquiry
♫ Because it ain't a secret ♫
You won't find this in a diary
- So you made the video?
- Yes, I made the video
super, super low budget.
Not fancy at all.
I shot it on my iPhone.
- The way I like it.
- Yeah, I went to a studio that's,
probably, as fancy as I got.
- So you rented studio space?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Where?
- There's this studio in Syracuse
called SubCat Videos.
Did the song there.
- Where do you live?
- I live in Syracuse.
Pretty much do the video.
I wasn't going to put it up when
I submitted the application to you guys,
it was like.
- A private link to that.
- Yeah, yeah but the Pomsey Kid.
I asked him what he thought about it
and he's like, "Man, his could go viral."
Go figure and I'm like,
it's cool and all but at the same time,
it's, kind of, silly.
- I get it.
- People might hate on it or whatever.
But I take his advise.
I put it on YouTube, no traction.
It's like super slow.
I'm like digging on LinkedIn trying
to figure out who I can email here
'cause I felt like I just needed
somebody to sit in.
- Yeah of course.
- A friend of mine, he's' like,
"Hey man, you want me
to post it on reddit?"
I'm familiar with reddit.
I know if you can do something on reddit.
- The internet notices.
- Yeah, yeah.
So we toss it on reddit.
Like 30 minutes, get like 150 views.
I'm going nuts.
I can't, really, focus at work.
I'm sneaking on my phone,
oh my God, this is crazy.
From there it just blew up.
It's like 1.2 million views right now.
I'm just still trying to get
about how to do it again.
- I get it.
We all feel that after it happens.
So it went to 150 views
and, literally, you were just
refreshing every little bit?
- Yeah, my friends were just texting me,
Bro, it's on Worldstar now.
It's at 10,000 views,
it's at blah, blah, blah.
♫ Wasn't born with this
♫ I've grown with this
♫ Throughout my education
♫ ♫ I perform with this on daily basis
♫ I be detonating
I'm stoked but at the same time,
I couldn't even focus.
It's just so crazy.
- You been in a haze for a week?
- Yeah, yeah.
- So now you're here.
- Yeah, yeah, so now I'm here.
Trying to see where it goes.
- So were people reaching out to you
that you haven't talked to in a while?
- Yeah, aunties.
"Hey, I always knew that you."
- (laughs) I love it.
- I'm taking it all in 'cause I still
don't feel like but it's cool
but I didn't do anything.
I'd do it again.
- I get it, I get it.
- I'm not trying to let it get to my head.
- Yeah of course.
One viral video.
As you, you're smart, you get it.
There's a lot of people
that have done that.
It's about what you do next
and next and next and next.
- Exactly, yeah.
- So what would you like to happen?
You want to get a job here?
- Yeah.
- You'll move down here?
♫ Still live at my mama house
♫ But I'm cool with moving out
♫ To the Big Apple working for you
♫ Yeah I'm cool with that
- Okay and what do you want to do, design?
And learn all the other stuff?
Designs your core skill that you've had.
And then you want to learn whatever
the fuck else you can learn?
- Yeah, I kind of want.
♫ Every time I get behind computer
♫ I make a souffle
♫ I can fix you homie website
♫ I can even illustrate
I don't know, just dabble in things.
I know you have the team (mumbles).
I think I'm capable of handling
that kind of work. ♫ I'm a hard
worker and you can criticize
♫ And I won't take it personal
♫ I know there's room to rise
And then, I can show
you something actually.
- Please.
Tyler, get me Andy.
- Brian Frost for Inventor Sports,
had me do a test project.
So this is something for.
- Yep, yep.
- You guys don't have em or whatever but.
- Yep.
- He just asked me to see what
I could do with a video
more like a (mumbles).
I just, basically, just did a timeline
kind of concept for em.
Just to highlight that first.
The youngest guy to score
a touchdown since 1964.
And then is you slide.
Oh yeah, you already seen that.
- It's really cool.
- So that's what I did for him.
- I like it.
- I think I could do that stuff too.
- Something he mocked
up for that beaner ass.
Did you see this?
- It's nice.
- Yeah, I like the second piece a lot.
- I was, really, impressed with
the stuff that he sent
for you too actually.
- Did you see that song?
- I haven't yet.
- Okay.
- Yeah, you did it quickly.
He's from (mumbles), some jiffs.
- I don't remember which video it is.
- Can we please keep calling them gifs?
I'm kidding, I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
I know it's been, officially, rebranded
but I'm still pissed about it.
Okay, I mean where are we at with design?
I know you got a couple of people.
- [Andy] Yeah, it's a
combo that we can have.
There's a female Monica.
Ceaser starts this week
but he's more illustrator
than I had him pegged
to and we can debate.
- Okay.
♫ I hope to emphasize
♫ That for the job I'm fit
♫ And if you're pennywise
♫ Then you'll realize I'm really it
And I'll say I'm pro Photoshop.
- What's that?
♫ I'm a real counterpuncher
♫ I am not a counterfeit
I'm more Photoshop than illustrator.
- Listen, we need hard core design.
♫ Yes I'm cruising for a bruising
♫ I know winning comes with loosing
- Like, what you just made there
and if he's impressed.
If we can pull it off, we
could move quickly here.
Can you pull it up?
- Yeah.
- Can you pull it up while we talk?
I mean I think that's our
biggest need right now.
- [Andy] Yeah it is.
- I mean right?
- [Andy] Yeah and then there's
the secondary combo is the
media account creators.
- Right.
- [Andy] You know what I mean?
- Yeah, of course I do.
- This is from Daily (mumbles)
and this was just a content I
built around striking things.
I thought you said throughout that.
Just like meme stuff but then.
♫ But enough of my lips moving
♫ Hire me let's get to proving
- The eat shit that was real funny.
Yeah man, I think we should do it.
I think it's a funny story
for everybody on the internet.
I think he's, clearly, got the skills
to be able to do it.
And more importantly, I think that we can
motivate millions of people to go
and get there's too.
I think we owe it to him
and I think we owe it to them
to make this hire.
I think it'll make the
full circle feel real good.
When can you start?
- I would ask for, maybe, just a month
just so I don't leave.
- Yeah you got stuff to do.
Plus you got to figure out where
you're gonna live and everything.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Alright, so why don't you guys
talk details of price and everything
so he can have some time to figure it out.
But I'd be okay with him joining the team.
- Okay, that's sweet.
Man, thank you man.
- You're welcome.
So why don't you guys talk details
right now while I go to my next meetings.
And let me know if there's any friction.
If he can afford it, he can't afford it.
Anything that's logistically needed.
- Alright.
- Alright?
- Hey thank you man.
- Your welcome man, congrats.
- Hey, thank you.
- Good, you guys go jam.
♫ Count
- And that's how you do it.
That's pretty cool.
♫ I got, I got, I got
♫ Internship on internship is on my resume
♫ In that visual communications
♫ I got BFA
♫ Every time I get behind computer
♫ I make a souffle
♫ I can fix your homie website
♫ I can even illustrate